[Filburt] We were floating around
the universe for the past 20 years.
[Heffer] Ooh! We're passing Earth again.
Push... the... button!
[buzzes]
[all screaming]
We're home.
[all cheering]
I don't think we're in the '90s anymore.
-[siren wails]
-[grunts]
[screams]
[laughing]
-[beeping]
-[grunting]
I just got the new O-Phone 9.
[both] Ten!
[Filburt] It's so realistic!
-[bell dinging]
-[grunts]
The 21st century
is a very dangerous century.
I'm gonna find some episodes
of The Fatheads.
That's been off the air for years.
That show is all I have!
We're going on an epic quest
to find the great Ralph Bighead.
Let's go!
[laughing]
[laughs]
Ralphie!
Why don't you go back
to the '90s where you belong?
[all] Yeah!
[flatulates]
Oh, that wind came out of the wrong end.